hey guys in this video we're gonna talk
about something called fight tights okay
now it's kind of gotten a bad rap and
considered an anti-nutrient when in fact
it's not really an anti-nutrient per se
I'm gonna cover why it's not but phytic
acid is a very powerful antioxidant in
certain things like nuts and seeds like
the fiber and the rice and the fiber
around the grain beans and a small
amount in vegetables so it's there to
protect the seed from growing so it's
kind of like a natural preservative or a
protective thing and it is true that
when you consume foods with too much of
this it can block your zinc and your
iron and other minerals but in this
video I want to focus more on the seeds
and the nuts because if you're on a
ketogenic diet you're not going to be
consuming rice or grains or beans you
will be consuming vegetables and
sometimes people will say well you
shouldn't be consuming nuts and seeds
because of the high levels of phytic
acid well if you're consuming some seeds
and some nuts and other foods you're
going to be totally fine and I'm gonna
tell you why
so number one did your microbes the
friendly bacteria in your gut actually
make fight case that is the enzyme that
breaks down phytic acid so your body has
the capacity dismantle excess amounts of
phytic acid and your body will adapt to
it if you actually consume seeds and
nuts in a regular basis your microbes
will give you more of this and this will
help make sure you don't have an excess
amount of phytic acid alright number two
vitamin c in the vegetables that you
should be consuming okay increase the
absorption of iron which can be
inhibited when you have phytic acid okay
number three beta carotene and leafy
greens also increase the absorption of
iron so if you're doing the greens that
will also help you absorb these minerals
alright number four adding meat to your
vegetables will also increase the
absorption of iron cooking or steaming
your vegetables decrease phytic acid so
when you're consuming vegetables it's
not a bad idea to steam or cook some of
them but make sure you have at least
with them raw as well because you get
benefits both ways when you actually
steam or cook you enhance certain
phytonutrients you also decrease some of
these so called anti nutrients at the
same time but when you consume more raw
you get more enzymes so I think a
balance of half raw and half steamed or
cooked would be a good thing all right
number six fermenting vegetables like in
sauerkraut and those pickles will
decrease phytic acid number seven most
people have too much iron as they get
older especially men our body is very
difficult time getting rid of iron but
they can actually absorb iron so if
you're consuming iron from a supplement
or you're consuming the wrong foods like
let's say you're doing a lot of pasta or
breads which is fortified with iron
which is a big mistake
you're gonna start accumulating more and
more iron that iron can actually go into
the liver and cause cirrhosis it can go
into the pituitary gland then affect
your gonads to the point where your
testosterone is really low it can go
into the pancreas and even if cause
diabetes it can go into the brain and
cause dementia so too much iron is very
very bad as you get older and you're
consuming leafy greens and more nuts and
you're concerned about fighting acid
because it's gonna deplete your iron
it's one of the best things to help
regulate excessive amounts of iron it
can actually chelate or pull out
excessive amounts of iron so it's a good
thing and if you're eating other foods
in your diet like for example sea foods
you're gonna get plenty of minerals
including the zinc and other trace
minerals which made be depleted by
phytic acid alright thanks for watching
if you're liking this content please
subscribe now and I will actually keep
you updated on future videos